right now we have a very special guest
in studio with Maurice Gary Mandela the
CEO of colour are yes and Colour art one
of the generous sponsors to the st.
Louis Chess Club in the work that
they're doing here Gary welcome to the
show thank Ranier your bio that you've
been in color art since 1985 that's
correct they must like you apparently
they do I bet I've had a great run at
color art and in large part to the
fantastic people in our organization it
makes my job easy you know that's why
the CEO gets the big bucks the people
who work for you well before we get into
color art and the amazing work you could
do there tell me how are you guys
involved here in the Chess Club with
your dinner generosity and why variety
of reasons actually I I have been a
chess player for the longest time my
father got me going on chess when I was
a little boy and I had a deep-seated
love for chess as a byproduct of that
and enjoyed the game and then
interestingly enough there was a movie
that came out in 2015 or 16 the queen of
cot way I'm sure you would remember it
and it reads my love for chess and as
that progressed I reached out to the
chess club reached out to Lauren and
became a member of the gala committee
last year and just loved everything
about that whole process so it's
combination of my heritage playing chess
and some of the things I've seen in the
last few years that's fabulous and I was
indeed a great movie very inspiring we
have new stories coming out now as we
had a youngster tani Ottawa me refugee
from Nigeria who won a state
championship and New York state
championship and is now blowing up the
airwaves so the stories continue tell us
in your role at your job
what is it on a day to day basis great
question great question you know you
love to get involved in the day-to-day
part of the business but as a CEO of an
organization it is so difficult to be
involved in each one of those elements
so I keep my focus around our mission
our vision and make sure we're
respecting those elements and then the
strategic initiative
that we are implementing as an
organization all of that is critical and
if you if you allow your focus to wander
too much from those things it becomes
significant in the performance of the
business then ultimately all of those
things are very high-minded
but in addition to that the results of
the organization monitoring that
tweaking the business when it needs to
be tweaked looking at opportunities for
growth organic as well as acquisition so
that's where I spend most of my time
we're seeing some of the great interior
design work you do there and you're in
you know all those places around the
country yeah yeah that is actually a
passion of mine we started a group
actually just rebranded the group last
year it's called color art sports now
and like it has a Busch Stadium their
Busch Stadium yeah very good very good
we the reason why we got into color arts
sports was when Busch Stadium was being
renovated actually being rebuilt and
there was an opportunity there and
through a number of conversations with
the contractor Hunt's construction we
were able to open up a couple new doors
for us in that segment and as anyone
that's really engaged in the sports
scene these days realizes universities
colleges professional franchises are
renovating and building new stadiums at
a rapid pace and as you looked at that
you could see that we've done about 15
or 16 stadiums currently we'll really
yeah thank you thank you and we've
touched a large part of the nation for
opportunities where new stadiums are
coming on the ground that was Busch
Stadium you just saw up there and I
think we're also looking at Busch there
as well so this gives you a sampling
those images give you a nice sampling of
some of the projects we've done
nationally looking at all these other
place city I'm a New Yorker you're in
Citi Field with the New York Mets play
the myths yeah we did the myths it was
great mostly the Yankees up there though
by the way do you have a Yankee fan
there's a story would you like to hear
it please
we actually after we completed the Mets
the Yanks were due in their Stadium
shortly thereafter and
yeah exactly and we approach the Yanks
and and interesting learning moment
frankly we we said we did the Mets and
and you wouldn't have thought there was
intermurals between the Mets and the
eggs
yeah well that's it that was a done deal
exactly right it was a national league
an American League team and I was not on
that but it was sorry yeah
tell us you there's something
interesting over in your bio that I
think really pertains to chess and our
chess fans out there the the you read a
book called in search of excellence
that's actually prompted you to be
become a part of this company which
you've been at now since 85 what's a
secret proposition to the success in
your company and and how does that
connect back to chest as you can see it
the idea that you know what what is it
about excellence and striving for it
that keeps a company like yours that
what gives a winning edge and you know
if you don't want to tell too many trade
secrets because you've got competitors
out there we'll keep it a secret yeah
okay we will do that we was not really
being broadcast to all over the world I
understand it block out the if you take
a look at our mission and vision and
those are our core beliefs if you go out
on our website color - art comm you'll
you'll see what our secret sauce is we
don't we don't really keep it undercover
at all we really focus on connecting
using knowledge to connect people in
space and believe it or not these days
c-suite executives are really spending a
lot of time focusing on collaboration in
their corporate environment attracting
retaining and engaging and that is the
most part most important part and there
there is a belief today that has shaped
up that space for a long time was viewed
as an expense in other words
it's something that hits the PNL and
costs us money today space is viewed as
an asset in categories of optimizing
real estate and so forth
so what do we do to facilitate that we
try and bring knowledge to the table in
every engagement that we have with a
client that comes in a lot of forms
primary research case studies insights
secondary research reaching out to some
of the academics around the world the
Harvard Business Review I actually had a
client the other day in a major st.
Louis company say to me Gary I really am
NOT interested in what's going on in
space today but can you tell me what's
going to be happening in the next two to
three years and that moment was an
eye-opening moment for me that we we are
on the right path in terms of using
research to advance companies in the st.
Louis and the region final question for
you you're a chess player I am how does
chess help you in your day-to-day role I
think the easy answer on that is it
helps you with strategy and so forth and
that's true it does but it builds
character
it really does build character and I'm
not stealing that from you I researched
you a little bit as well and I saw that
you you talked about character in one of
your books and character in individuals
is essential I I find that the ability
to implement to be able to stay the
course on a chess game stay focused on a
chess game drives parts of your brain
that frankly you don't even know is
being impacted I watch basketball a lot
the n-c-double-a s are going on right
now and I've started to look at
basketball believe it or not from a
strategic viewpoint that I never did
before until I started getting reengaged
in chess I can see why you're the boss
man for all these years thank you they
keep you around thank you very much for
your generous support in color art take
a look at their website folks great work
and great support for all that is chess
here in st. Louis question for you are
you a daddy are you a father right I am
a father yeah and do you teach your
children chess do you engage oh my
daughter happens to be standing right
over there right
that's Kelly hey Kelly
are you a chess player honest answer we
have good news for you we have ladies
night chess classes here on Thursday
nights wine cheese and chess lessons you
can't go wrong thank you Gary and thank
you for your support it's very very nice
thanks so much